hey guys Pete here was reading about the
renewal of Westworld for season two this
morning and found out there was a bit of
news about the prequel for Game of
Thrones I'm gonna talk about what some
of the prequel options are so that we
can talk about what we'd like to see
stick around to the end of the video to
find out about the book giveaway I'm
doing right now because I want you to
win not much spoilers if any in this
video so let's jump right into it the
interview that I'm talking about was
with Casey boys who is HBO's President
of Programming the interviewer asked
have Game of Thrones prequel talks with
george RR martin yet yielded a specific
idea at this point that might get put
into development mr. bully's responded I
would say it's still kind of preliminary
ongoing talks there are areas we are
exploring but I wouldn't point to anyone
and say this is what we're going to do
so not much of a reveal except when he's
been asked the same kind of question
before he hadn't gone as far to say that
they were even considering what it would
look like I can't find the original
article I'm thinking about but in his
previous statements were along the line
of well we would love to do more Game of
Thrones on HBO then he would pivot to
the fact that Dan and Dave aren't
interesting doing another show they've
been working on this non-stop for a long
time at this point and they Britt they
basically came out and said that if they
decide to make a prequel they won't be
involved at the Emmys when the press
asked george RR martin about it he said
there was plenty of material but that
their sole focus right now is to finish
the original series if we look at what
Blois says at this point it sounds a lot
like the prequel will happen since why
would he mention ongoing talks if that
might come back to bite him later this
isn't a big surprise since Game of
Thrones has become an institution for
HBO I've guessed they would do this for
the sheer amount of material they have
to work with and the fact that if it's
done well there's really no reason why
they wouldn't be able to have the same
success so I think it's basically
confirmed because that's what I want to
believe obviously there are things that
could happen that could kill the project
but I'll be ignoring those because I'm a
fan and I don't
at the end after next year what what a
prequel focus on that I'm gonna lay out
the most likely candidates and then you
guys can tell me what you think first
things first the world is built up
around the main story that has become
the TV series Game of Thrones is huge
there's almost an infinite amount of
possibilities for this video I'm going
to exclude the ones that are super cool
but wholly unlikely to be made the first
potential candidate would be the tales
of Duncan a this is a collection of
short novels about Sir Duncan the tall
and Aegon v Targaryen who is a boy when
the series begins there are three
published novellas which is a fancy way
of saying a short novel that were just
recently repackaged into an anthology
called a night of the Seven Kingdoms
why is Duncan egg the most likely
candidate well for one there are already
books and for another it is related to
the world that show watchers know while
being removed enough by time that it
isn't the same characters just when
they're younger
with these stories make for a show
that's as exciting as Game of Thrones
that's a bit of a hard question to
answer because they're definitely
different the duncan egg stories that
have come out to this point are focused
on one event there's a story that has a
beginning and an end in each one of the
novellas it's not arranged in these
cliffhanger scenarios that continue from
one story to the next at the same time
they are all tied into the big story and
even though there are only three
published martin says that he intends
that it would be about 12 of them all
together at the end in the timeline i
imagine based on what we know about
these characters towards the end is
where it would really tie into the
things show people only would really
know about we don't know a lot about the
end of Aegon v life because martin has
kind of made this like a blank spot on
purpose but what we pretty much know is
that when Rhaegar is born around that
time Aegon is trying to hatch a dragon
egg and that this leads to the tragedy
at summer hall were his and dunks lives
come to an end I think the stories are
good and like where it's headed
I'll admit it isn't perfect though the
two central characters are probably not
as compelling as those we have in the
show right now when you first meet them
I mean egg is a kid do
the sex of the show that's out now there
this would be a project on a massive
scale and the material is there to work
with I was giving away the collection
version of the three Duncan egg novellas
in my first book giveaway and received a
lot of comments complaining that people
don't want this to happen mostly for the
things I just touched on I think they
are generally well received by fans but
like I said they're definitely different
than the main series the second option
is a prequel that would be right before
the current events of a game of Thrones
that we know Robert's rebellion or the
War of the usurper went down just about
eighteen years prior to the show's
current timeline or when the show starts
I should say it involve characters
people know already it has a lot of
potential to fill in some of the
backstory people have been theorizing
about for a very long time the actual
war itself only lasted a year or a
little bit more than a year but there is
plenty that happens in the lead-up that
could fill plenty of seasons without
problems there aren't too many downsides
on this one except that we already know
the outcome but I guess that would be
the same with any prequel of anything
even if you know who wins the Battle of
the Trident it would still be amazing to
watch people have long said that this
would make a great movie which I don't
disagree with it all but I don't see
where stretching it out into a series
would take anything away from it either
it has fanservice and that people get to
see characters they know doing things
they only read about or watch you heard
about in the TV show and it has
potential for some major nerd service if
it addresses some of the theories about
what was going on with you know the
major houses and different things before
the tourney at Harrenhal actually
happens one thing that we can't ignore
when thinking about this option though
is that when it comes to actors it's in
a weird window we have a person we know
an actor a real guy that is King Robert
who can't you know we can't throw him
back into the show as a 20 year younger
version of himself same with the
Lannister twins and basically everyone
else they would have to pick people that
sort of looked like the actors who play
the older versions of themselves but
also are great actors so that could be a
hurdle another choice would be the dance
of the Dragons which is laid out in two
novellas called the princess and the
Queen and the rogue Prince as far as
popularity is concerned amongst the
fandom I think these are equally popular
when compared to the tales of Dunkin egg
there are a couple problems with this
choice though and the first is that it
revolves around dragon it's not just a
random dragon here there but tons of
dragons all the time this is the period
of Westeros is history where the dragon
population was at its absolute peak at
least and you know I know someone's
gonna say something like oh well there
were ancient dragons yeah but in what we
know that's written down there are two
Targaryen factions that get into a civil
war and both sides basically have a
stable of dragons behind them this
sounds awesome
but the budget of filming this should
come to mind I mean even though Game of
Thrones is a huge success
HBO still is a business the second
concern is that these are historical
reports more or less written down
through the maesters so the writing
isn't as directly relatable to TV I know
people who love these stories will
disagree and believe me I thoroughly
enjoyed them myself but if you really
think about it historical counts are
more fun for already invested fans also
there isn't really a good side and a bad
side which I think on some level is
important for an ongoing series I mean
people would likely pick a side in the
war but at the end of the day the
story's more about how they destroyed
themselves through war in general you
know that nobody really stands out as
the good guy or the bad guy and while
this is you know typical and George's
writing I just don't know that it
translate at translates as well to TV
one last option that seems ready made
for TV would be Aegon's conquest how the
Targaryen came to Westeros and conquered
the Seven Kingdoms this time in history
has only one side with dragons but it
also has a lot of action it wouldn't be
a stretch for show only fans to jump
into this story it's the furthest from
removed time wise from the other options
I've mentioned which could be good or
bad depending on
you look at it at the same time it's the
sort of story though that the name alone
kind of explains the whole thing while
they could definitely build these
characters out and make it very
watchable my own experience is that when
it's mentioned in the history is just a
thing that happened an important thing
but not the most legendary stuff that
exists in this world when I first read
through the world of Ice and Fire for
example like Aegon the first didn't
strike me as the most interesting
Targaryen king but he's one that
everyone knows and one that had a big
hand in shaping the world our stories
existing right now beyond those which I
think are the most obvious let me know
if you think I left something out though
we start getting into wishlist territory
like valaria you know before the doom
and the doom would be awesome but do you
think they're trying to go into such
unexplored territory I mean there is a
ton of information related to the
balerion freehold but is it is literally
like a different world from the one that
we're watching you know the current Game
of Thrones show exists in of course you
could go east or you could go away back
in time or you could just pick one area
and talk about the you know how that
house came to be or you could talk about
the Age of Heroes and so on and so forth
I think most of the stuff and this vein
is unlikely but if you have a compelling
reason why in the context of a TV show
something like that would be like the
thing that makes the most sense
definitely let me know so where do you
stand on these options do you think it's
a done deal that some prequel at all
will get made what do you think is most
likely and what would your crazy wish
list one be are any of the ones I
mentioned doomed to fail as a prequel in
your opinion anyways thanks for watching
and I hope you can get a good
conversation going and going on in the
comments there's no lack of material and
ideas but which ones are the most doable
and tie-in with the broader fan base and
would basically end up being the best
show as mentioned I have started a new
book giveaway and I do want you to win
or at least I want someone to win the
way it works is when I hit 28,000
subscribers I will pay
one commenter and send that person a
copy of the new 20th anniversary edition
of a game of Thrones
I'll put an Amazon link in the
description so you can give it a look if
you haven't seen it yet but it's
Illustrated and it's pretty awesome all
you have to do is be a subscriber and
then leave a comment on this video or
any of the other recent videos that I
have where I mentioned this specific
giveaway if you're curious at how I pick
the winner go and watch my Dragonstone
video because I at the end of that one I
picked the last winner thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon